oh baby the wait is over new dates added
on the middle class famous store gang
we're coming to see you bring the squad
out live stand up comedy show play a
little energy with the crowd great way
to introduce some people to the show
bring the squad out Kippy straighten
these bozos out the fat man ain't lying
folks uh this week we got Nashville and
indy and then in November we have two
shows in Atlanta as part of the red clay
Comedy Festival get those tickets then
we're going to Charlotte North Carolina
also we have a sold out show in
Philadelphia Two Sold Out shows in
Philadelphia sorry smell you next time
Philly uh Providence Rhode Island we
just had a second Show tickets available
in December Boston the same thing we had
in the second Show tickets still
available get those tickets those shows
will sell out we'll see you there see ya
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage little shall we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find that if they're good to be classy
just a big old piece of trash I'm your
host Dave trolley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antodi's basement she's upstairs playing
pickleball with the neighbors kid okay
Mike Carlos is coming at you from right
next to me he is the CEO of are you
garbage he is an international
businessman he is not to be trifled with
in the boardroom or the bedroom but he's
my best pal in the whole wide world and
I love him give it up for KJ Kevin James
Ryan Hey gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure your rate of you
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those are bizarre
Buckhead and obviously
um wait let me pull up my files
www.patreon.com stop playing stupid
check out the greatest goddamn website
of all time Google kick rocks and Amazon
you stink anything else Facebook you're
doing all right uh but patreon.com the
[ __ ] out yes sir how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man makes us all look good
works the ones and twos crosses the t's
dots the eyes give it up for T-Bone
mcgruffins Toby McMullen everybody
what's up dudes pal I just met this guy
we got in here and I love him
he's a good [ __ ] the bird's got a
good [ __ ] I'll tell you that right now
he's a good hang I can tell you that
gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly special guest back
with us again today uh for the second
time he's an OG came in into the show
very early back in the day like one of
the first 10 episodes live maybe so do
yourself a favor go back check it out
he's absolutely fantastic stand-up
comedian he has a brand new special out
right now called check right which you
can find over there on the used tube at
YouTube slash Andrew Fury or you can
check out his website andyfury.com time
ladies and gentlemen Eddie Theory yeah
there he is the boys and one hell of a
drinking partner a big guy oh I love
going out with the with the boys two
three pops with Mr fiori three in about
a half hour
you know what Sam Morel say which I've
been thinking about since he was here
and you'll appreciate this there's
nothing like being drunk in a New York
City Bar yeah in the winter and coming
out in that cold hit you I was gonna say
we could have ended that sentence right
after barely could be a drunk in a bar
it's just something being drunk in a bar
it is this is the best time of year for
drinking it's fall this first of all you
don't hate drinking in July yeah I'm not
shunning that either I like those summer
losers what this is a bunch of fatsos
here this is our weather this is our
this is our clothing this is our time to
shine because this is the first time all
year when October hits I'm not just
standing and sweating sure just doing
this yeah you know what's bad when
you're looking for where the air
[Laughter]
yeah exactly you know what I'm saying
I'll tell you what it's a nice move
though now Donnelly got me on this is
the uh ami Jukebox app yeah yeah cutting
everybody in line these guys are such
bar flies they've downloaded the Jukebox
app to their phone so they can [ __ ]
Flex on other drunk idiots I don't even
want to get off my stool and walk over
to the Jukebox folks are you tired of
waiting for your favorite ABBA song to
come on
well we got a trick for you hear it now
I'm spending three tokens like a
Dominican pimp okay I'm all out of
credits yeah I gotta [ __ ] then I'm
all drunk and I gotta hook it back up to
my bank account and I can't figure it
out on my TD Bank app that's a [ __ ]
nightmare would you be the guy at a
member remember when diners would have
the little jukeboxes in in the little
buddy was that you was that you and your
family I loved it fighting over who gets
to play Johnny Johnny North Jersey
diners was our whole High School scene
yeah you know I mean as a kid that's
like an eight-year-old kid to have that
you literally felt like a radio DJ I was
like flipping I know this song doing
time and temperature doing the weather
up weather on Tuesday
and the time and temp is 10 45 I got my
curfew at 11. so I got to get out of
here folks I gotta hightail it out of
here Cloudy with a Chance of mozzarella
sticks
out
here's a slow one for the kids
everybody coming from a broken home it
goes with good with a little pork like
and cheese Billy Joel everybody hey
actually it does really good it's really
real appealing it really hits the spot
buddy congrats on a new special check
right thanks man you were telling us
before where does that exactly come from
my my lazy dad you know I had an old dad
I had an old time Dad wasn't lazy his
father was a very accomplished Man
fought in World War II and won
on The Winning Side
how funny yeah Andy's dad is a World War
II vet oh really United States
goddamn 101st Airborne kicked the [ __ ]
out of him
he didn't see it coming can't even watch
Panda Brothers
Fun World War II he was an Olympian and
really didn't have kids till he was 55
shout out what was the Olympian in
Lacrosse in 1950 in London I like how
you did that man yeah got it that's when
I played with played with the wooden
sticks back I got I still have the
wooden stick she's at home yeah I have
my little sister's got like refurbished
we gave it to him as a Christmas gift
which is also a trash move is you give
somebody a gift that already belongs to
them oh yeah
you just cleaned it off and repackaged
it put some pledge on this thing yeah
yeah my dad got his wedding ring back
one year I swear to God yeah from the
pawn shop that's all my family we are
not good gift givers we give gifts like
something that you can do with the
person where it's like yeah I'll give
you hockey tickets but I'm going yeah
we're going with you I got you I got
your tickets to see my favorite band and
we're not sitting together
you got two rows Up Guys and Dolls it's
not guys and guys
big Seinfeld fan this young man oh me
and Kippy can go we can talk in Seinfeld
I think yeah we do a lot after I mean
after a handful of beers we really get
into the nitty-gritty chop it up Jerry
Style
I forgot the whole [ __ ] point of
check right so yeah when uh so he was an
old dad he didn't have kids so he was 55
I was so you were 10 he was 65. wow
that's the math I always do I go when I
was 15 he was 70. That's crazy dude yeah
like 20 years old 75. and totally still
kicked the show yeah it was in great
shape his entire like until six months
before he had a big guy like you because
you're uh
he's only five eleven it's her mom six
too
my mom seven four
you look like you drink beer out of the
barrel yeah
my mom
's with dinner every single night
every single night till about 18. what
does the mailman of the neighbor look
like I know so you got a handful you
know what's weird is that all three of
my best friends were going home all six
feet and above none of our parents are
tall very fishy yikes is somebody put in
the water down there yeah that or the
mailman was a real slippery one
slippery one is a great time
he's seven feet tall
always knowing the mail's here Tony uh
so you know my dad
as
he got older you know when I was like
eight I started to notice this thing
that my dad would do when he was driving
we'd come up to an intersection he'd
look left he'd just go check right oh so
you oh yeah you were the eyes on them
yeah you were the eyes on the right side
of the world yeah
we'd get that too how am I doing over
there I hit that I'm like what the [ __ ]
is this dude I know I don't know the
timing and the distance in the [ __ ]
side yeah my mind is still developing
here dude his hand is closing in pretty
quick but I think he can get it here's
the other thing you learn real quick not
to mumble words that sound similar one
time I gave him a no he heard go and
took off right into traffic anyone you
got to give him an all clear something
you gotta really shout and another he
didn't hear great either only here yeah
he was a hundred right I know he was in
his late thousands
holy [ __ ] you're in a car seat man in
the 50 cal yeah yeah you're riding
shotgun literally that explains all
these dents on the right side of the
vehicle
that's really good I like that yeah man
he was a class he was a classic American
character dude so yeah we named it after
check right and uh yeah really it's
getting released on 10-6 which would
have been his 99th birthday so it's a
little sentimental yeah that's fantastic
that's awesome buddy and Andy's a killer
make sure you go check out the [ __ ]
special check it out I like it 100 we
love you to death
um it's been a minute it has so the
show's evolved a little bit since you
were since you were on the program uh
before we get into the patreon questions
we wanted to hit you with a couple all
right
we'll check up um something I haven't
had in four years oh you and me both
sister really let's check up you stay
away from the doctor I don't like that
news I don't like that news I don't want
to know what's going on in the weekend
no I don't want to know what's gurgling
really when's the last time you were at
the dentist dentist I'm good at I do
twice a year because I have dental okay
so I go get the cleaning twice a year
the dentist I don't do the dentist but
the eye exam I'm not bad with I like
going to the eye doctor since I think
last time was I got Lasik real yeah
wow do you have to come out of pocket
for that or is that covered little
covered but then mostly out of uh what
are we talking
four large Four G's about two an eye
hey Doc just do the one all right I'll
be back in a couple of a couple of
months
I gotta save some nickels and dungeons
before we can do righty about two and I
just do the one I like that you're just
going like this every time you drive
my depth perception is all off yeah I
can't put the left one on the AmEx or
not you guys take Discover
getting Lasik on a Diners Club card like
a dirt bag
Ah that's good well worth it though what
is the credit card situation over there
at your house what are you rocking Amex
Delta okay what color gold good solid
you I owe them a nice chunk of change
yeah
they always come knocking tomorrow
tomorrow oh really it's like it's like
those [ __ ] are waiting around a
calendar all goddamn day hey come in and
take your eyes
I talk to you for a second
um what are we talking ballpark uh you
how many I have two cards I have two
credit cards what do you got to break
off tomorrow and you pay it all at the
end of the month you little roll over
yeah you're a sweet kid
[ __ ] country bumps
you had to pay it all at the end of the
month you used to you used to but if you
have a good news
they still want you to I just don't
I mean legally I'm obligated by the
terms and conditions that pay on a fifth
uh no if you have a good track record
they'll let you uh they just Institute
like a pay overtime yeah
and I need that Breathing Room
my lungs are collapsing your goddamn
scuba dive right now
every bubble I can get if you come up
too fast you get the bends what are you
doing you give me a number
and then I'll tell you if you're close
you have 10 grand in your credit card
you're [ __ ] sweet what more than that
yeah
I'm paying this off over time 25. yeah
we're in the ballpark holy here next
round's on me donations at Andy fiori
venmo anybody wants to help me knock
that down a little bit of every little
bit helps others a little you know a
long way
you're like UNICEF over here going
around a Halloween is that is that big
purchases or is that just you wait they
just self-produce a special that all
right that took a nice chunk of change
okay to make that happen and look pretty
and pay all the people there you go and
production cost that's all right
absolutely oh yeah we're talking to the
IRS at the end of the year
I got an Asian kid he knocks it out
they're getting crazy you guys like the
Jukebox huh hey guys I'm now a charity
by the way
I'm knowledge of the first church of
Andy fiori thank you Joel stealing it
over here
yeah dude we gotta fight I gotta make
some changes okay all right so uh yeah
what was the credit card talk uh so you
got the AmEx gold and what else you got
I got a Capital One oh okay yeah and
that one is really for emergencies
because I like using the MX because I
get the sky miles Sky miles that's why
that's how they keep it keep you on the
wheel so you you keep that one down that
one's there's not too much on it not at
all oh that's wrong that's for emergency
together like last call
or if the wings look good
these jukebox jukebox tokens aren't
paying for themselves is that the steak
sandwich you know what
yeah it's an emergency let's go holy
what's the limit on that one it's like
five grand I I actually that's more than
maybe I don't really use that one it's
wild I mean dude you have an Amex that
you had that you can put 25 kids don't
give me the limit they go you can just
have 30 grand I go that's not gonna be
good hey buddy you're gonna regret this
exactly I mean yeah that's like when you
cover the phone
oh that sounds good thank you very much
yeah you just try to rush him off the
phone oh yeah whatever you say this is
legally this is legally binded oh my
Lord yes and then I just got my debit
card which I try and use that number one
you know yeah of course of course of
course who who you rock with TD TD
touchdown Bank shout Outback man it used
to be Commerce I go I rock with you've
been rocking rocks it's the big c yeah
the blue and red whoa yeah baby if you
so you've been that was that your the
first that was 20 years in college I had
a checking account in college because
you had uh yeah uh Villanova University
baby Commerce shout out to the Wildcats
absolutely wow 2016 2018 National
Championship Philly's looking all right
and it could be a bad situation by the
time this when this comes out
um Phillies are in the [ __ ] playoffs
for the first time in 11 years bird gang
are doing well
on it's all right
um and you're over there in Queens now
story baby you're in Astoria you live
solo you got you got Solo solo yeah
where you do your food shopping C-Town
whoa
yikes no Amex I'll pull you out of a
seat here no kidding C-Town is
no no c-town's a tough one's trash just
for the folks out there that don't live
in the uh the tri-state area when you're
in a story you want to be at a Trade
Fair you want to be the Key Food Tracy
town is on my block yeah you could get a
human liver at [ __ ] C-Town ha
they do like they do LASIK in the back
they got horse meat my friend Jay rieman
Center eats horse all the time
I thought C-Town was okay I'll be honest
fellas I'm not a big grocery Shopper
okay are you ordering it a lot of
seamless where do you think that [ __ ]
25 candy comes from
you can run up a seamless tab with a
couple of mozzarella sticks of coke cost
me 43 holy [ __ ] that's what I like to
see it's such a rip-off but I'm such a
lazy piece I know do you right there
with you do you pay the rent on the 50
you paid on the first no I'm good I pay
the rent on the first I get that out of
the way because that's the that's the
first thing come knocking on the door if
you don't have it and you know a story I
got a little greek landlady she's in the
laundromat on the corner 24 7. so I
can't even avoid her I can't duck her
she'll be tackling me into the street
okay oh that's respectable I don't know
I assume this is Nationwide but you
really don't have to pay your rent until
the fifth because of social security
purposes I know that's the way it is in
the city you know what it's not the
passive aggressiveness I would get from
them real is not worth it really I
respect that I respect it on both ends
I'm always on the fifth that goes
underneath the door that's the credit
card 1159 the beginning of the month is
a tough time for the kid
you gotta space him out a little bit I
wish I could I wish I could anytime I
get an option do you want this on the
first of the 15th I'm like give me the
15th yeah give me a couple weeks that's
when the dust settles a little bit get
your [ __ ] head on let me get my head
on straight let me talk to some people
see some numbers I don't remember them
giving me the option on the 15th I was
just listening to I was reminded of a
story of I remember I called him one
time this is probably three this is
right before the pandemic I called him
on the phone with uh Time Warner
somebody you know Con Ed somebody about
what time they process the payment like
at what time it's gonna be taken bank
account and I'm like dude you're I'm
like you're trash he's like nah he's
like I just need a couple hours I'm like
dude you're calling if you're calling to
buy a few minutes just give me to 5 30.
yeah if you're gonna hit me before lunch
spinning who gets up before noon come on
what are we doing here real
overachievers down there Time Warner
what's the is the credit score good
though the credit score is not bad
because I make the payment every month
but uh seven hundy oh I tried you got it
once you're in the couple thousands that
minimum shoots right up okay uh I am
it's it's oh seven dollars oh yeah yeah
yeah we're right around there yeah it's
good are you a minimum payment guy
this month I am
you got to pay that full balance here's
the thing I've had I've had more than
the minimum like even if it's ten
dollars more than a minimum because
otherwise you're just paying interest
I've had really bad credit in you know
college I went on a CD shopping spree
and that [ __ ] got me in debt and then
it's it but it's people don't realize
how if you can say these like music yeah
why don't you just do Columbia House
like everybody else I did that what
you're the guy that they jammed up ran
out of names
here's my thinking I'm gonna we're
looking for Clint Parker I'm a collector
I like having things I like things on
the shelves I like the things to look at
so in my head I was like I'm gonna be a
I'm gonna be like a cool music guy and
like people are happy people have a
collection people come over to my house
and they'll be like because you guys got
good taste you know do you still have
these CDs I [ __ ] threw them all my
mom moved and I go Chuck them I don't
want to take them back Chuck them I got
the Air Max hangs up
what about DVDs you still have those I
still have my DVDs again Andy's a big
movie guy big movie I kept on it because
I still got a PlayStation you can watch
the movies anytime you want I can still
use a DVD how many how many DVDs are we
talking here probably about a hundred oh
huh same thing with music can you see
them if I walk into your house do I see
the collection on display okay yeah
that's true they've got their own
they've got their own Tower
that was my whole thing I was like
people are gonna come and uh and
appreciate my taste that's such a
college
yeah I know I thought it was gonna be
getting me laid
if you blow it they will come do you
have uh
um music posters on the wall framed or
unframed framed baby what are we talking
we we're talking uh there's some Hold
Steady which is a Brooklyn band that I
love oh that's even worse everything
sounds like you live in a Hard Rock Cafe
by the way
jacket framed I have guitars on the wall
too do you play apparently oh my God
what a bozo
they're purely for sure I don't have
strings on them they're the Guitar Hero
guitar I swear to God one has a hat on
it I just use it as a [ __ ] hat rack
at this point
[Laughter]
oh fiori Camp I got big news on Helix
baby what's that got one on the way yeah
yeah let's go got the fam on one two
went over there took the quiz brand new
mattress on the way everybody's raving
about Helix it's a really good time gang
you don't want to be walking around the
furniture store you want to do yourself
a favor get over to helix.com get
yourself a nice mattress and get a good
night's sleep listen if you're a
gentleman like myself right
a little trashy too but you try to make
nice nice decisions you know what I mean
you go to [ __ ] helixsleep.com you
take two minutes leave quiz I got lined
up with the Twilight matchers I loved it
so much I swung for the king size
mattress and I love you it's got me it's
got the it's got the bird it's got hanzi
Ponzi peen in it it's easy peasy don't
forget it uh plus uh Helix matches are
American made and come with a 10 or 15
year warranty depending on the model and
remember you get to try it out for 100
nights risk-free if you don't love it I
know you will because I do but if you
don't though they will pick it up and
give you a full runtime who even does
that Johnny Helix come straight to your
house picks up you don't like it that's
awesome don't uh don't take my word
forward helix has over uh has been
awarded number one mattress picked by GQ
and wired magazines even recommended by
multiple leading chiropractors and
doctors of sleep medicine it's a good
night's go-to solution for improving
your sleep do it baby here is the turkey
Helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners
go to helixleep.com garbage with Helix
better sleep starts now do it now the
word from our sponsor better help yeah
gang everyone's got things going on I do
this all the time I get caught up in the
problem I start focusing on that I start
obsessing over it and I don't start
looking at what can I do to solve the
problem you got to be solution oriented
you do you do and better online therapy
it's absolutely fantastic do yourself a
favor if you're working through
something get on better help yeah guys
uh I said uh like I've said a hundred
times before talk therapy has been a a
Big Tool in my life I use it in the past
and I recently signed up for better help
I'm a paying customer I'm a client I'm
the president the whole nine yards uh
it's great it's easy peasy to
communicate you don't have to like talk
to someone if you don't want to you can
just say an AKA a checkup this is going
on that's going on they follow up you
get a good response the whole nine yards
they kind of just walk you through a
little bit it's not intimidating you
don't have to like sit there in a weird
office with a guy with a coffee breath
being like where did he touch you or
whatever you want to do none of that
um so if you're thinking giving therapy
a try better help is a great option it's
convenient accessible affordable
entirely online get matched with the
therapist after filling out a brief
survey and switch therapists at any time
when you want to be a better Problem
Solver therapy can be there visit
betterhelp.com garbage today get 10 off
your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com garbage do it do it uh I got
the frame music posters there's a fish
one in there you're a big fish head or
deadhead both I love the dead Dead's my
favorite but uh I've got some frame
stuff I got some movie posters frames
what are we talking movies Cool Hand
Luke I've got an exorcist still when
he's when he's uh walking up to the
house it's got the light shining on him
that's frame you can throw anything in a
[ __ ] frame sure it's a little
classier yeah exactly I don't have
anything loose no I'm not an animal here
that Cool Hand Luke is an original print
oh I love it yeah my brother gave that
to me yeah I got a similar one it's like
that it's like blue and it's got them
digging the on the Chain Gang okay that
was pretty respectable how do you how
cool that is thank you uh you're a
single guy yeah right you're living you
got your own place out there yeah in
Queens
what's the what's what what's the is it
is it clean yeah it's clean beaning lady
once a month once a month 60 bucks
that's good though Mary comes she's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] once a month am I the only
one in this what are you looking like
once a month once a week I'll give you
you don't even have it's a week all
right clean though is that the only time
that happens straightening up I'm not
messy the biggest mess I make is leaving
clothes on the floor okay I got that
guitars on the wall I'm so scared of New
York City bugs and infestation I don't
keep [ __ ] out I throw [ __ ] away I try
and clean but you have a cleaning lady
come once a month dude it's all you need
to [ __ ] do the once over and you're
good it's really for the bathroom I
don't want to clean that thing sure you
know okay just got a tushy bidet though
tell you that much
[Applause]
it's an emergency
we're bringing a team
um have you ever bought the floor model
of an appliance or TV absolutely I
bought it my TV off the wall
I'll give you 80 bucks for it out the
door yeah Patty McGuire's giving me this
amount it's a 75-inch Samsung 2013.
I bought it on a Best Buy wall model
[ __ ] it's beautiful it's got one yeah
of course it does
it's got a tiny tiny tiny black ops
wait it's got it on the screen only I
see it one pixels it's got one little
it's like smaller than a pinhead this
little black dot the only time it comes
if you're watching a hockey game
that black dot on the ice shines through
Oh I thought it was the puck about 40
000 times get it what do you think
you're going the wrong way
[ __ ] backwards [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
how much did that take that take off a
good amount dude it's a 65 inch
I bought it in like 2015 it was like 600
bucks dude it's great it's a Samsung I'm
gonna I'll go to bat for this TV all
right all right I'm in I agree I
guarantee you won't even see it unless I
tell you where it is nobody has ever
come
it's like middle is it a corner upper
foreign
top right quadrant okay yeah that's not
too bad yeah does it end up on people's
faces and close-ups and stuff like I
said I know where it is and I barely
even see it okay it's because it's
mostly it yeah it's clearly in denial
dude a good deal is a good deal sure do
you have a do you have a stereo system
at the house not anymore you know how
long ago are we talking
five years okay I got the Bluetooth I
got the speakers okay yeah and there's a
TV hanging or is it hanging I got a guy
it's hanging and you have a one bedroom
or a studio one bedroom was there a TV
in the bedroom yeah really oh yeah also
how many dots on that thanks right
between the guitars
oh man that girl's gotta wake up there
and be like I gotta get the [ __ ] out of
here it's not bad I'll tell you uh I
bought a like a 30 inch
I don't know why I thought I knew 30
inch I know it's so small it looks like
a [ __ ] computer monitor on my wall
it's so small is it is it okay so if
your bet is your first of all is your
bed in the middle of the room like up
across the wall middle so you could walk
on either side of it yup do you have uh
night tables on either side yeah and is
the TV straight ahead of that yes 30
inches yeah picture in picture it's only
the picture though it's [ __ ] small
dude holy [ __ ] I'm a big I can't go to
sleep without it okay I can't do it I'm
always a [ __ ] adult night light and
it's uh do you set the timer is it
staying all night sleep timer no you
need a timer two hours okay yeah it's
not good to sleep with those TVs on you
that's why I turn it off yeah the two
hours anything on I agree I like the
two-hour moves the power class move
because the half hour the 15 minutes I'm
like just waiting for it to turn off I'm
like I'm getting anxious yeah it's gonna
shut off in the middle before the show
I'll tell you what's it then the scary
starts
actually [ __ ] Jeepers Creepers get
you ever set the two hour and you you go
you're laying awake at night and you go
I think I'm creeping up on the two hours
here yeah and then you see that you ever
have that TV shut off when you're still
up yeah it's a [ __ ] bad feeling
someone turn off
no good
oh God you have name brand luggage
Samsonite whoa not bad got it as a gift
though I did not purchase myself
hold on is it Christmas gift is it just
the roller or do you have like a set the
roller it's the stacker because you can
fit it in the overhead I made sure I
didn't want to check anything stacker
it's compact but you it Stacks up in it
it expands oh I know you're talking
about got an extra layer of zipper if
you keep that open you can get a couple
extra rows of teas in there gotcha throw
your board shorts in there yeah okay and
what uh you said you're a Delta man what
level uh status are you Delta diamond oh
holy [ __ ] a lot of flying damn
you guys got to be close no no I just
got silver but he did he just you're
also checking in under his name I know
you don't know we just got silver
for The Listener I've only tried
checking into a fight with my boarding
pass I show up 20 minutes later lady
goes oh sir you're Kevin Ryan I was like
yeah why didn't you have his because
they because he books them on under no I
didn't book those they
um you're not booking your own butts you
can't even go to the airport
he could he can't even check himself in
yeah when they ask fully they go did you
pack your own bag yes answer no
that's none of your business young lady
I've never heard somebody else or know
that question
uh no I'm wearing whatever giving you
give me does my packing
comes over the night before so who's
doing who's printing out their [ __ ]
boarding passes in 2020. yeah on my
phone that's why they're they're next to
each other they were they were like I
download I checked in uh and it
downloaded both so I sent it to him
thinking only sent his but I guess it's
Gotta Throw yours in the wallet bro
that's the move I put it in a while both
of them in the wall yeah my wallet is
well well here's the CSA who's Wallace
sometimes he forgets to put my TSA
pre-check number and I like what you're
making it his fault a little bit so he
forgets to put the team I didn't even
book these flights idiot fair enough
sometimes the TSA pre-check number isn't
there it happened once that happened
it's rare but for whatever reason it
doesn't take it it happens on his so
I'll use his to get through oh to go
through pre-check yeah oh I got jammed
up oh man and we were in LAX yesterday
right two days whenever the [ __ ] it was
they're not checking IDs for pre-checks
they light in the first right yeah the
checks on the thing they let you in the
Maze love that they let you in the Maze
we get there I go hey man but it's also
I'm like you can just I said hey it's
all not on there which he can just fix
you can just go online and you can fix
it himself but he doesn't so then we get
in there we get recognized this guy goes
oh you guys I know you you got a podcast
I know you do you got your podcast and
then he hands them his boarding pass
he's like sir you're not pre-checking
because yes I am she goes no sir you are
not he goes I'll tell you my number like
that's how it works you know what I mean
he's like I'm two four eight nine she's
like sir you have to get back you know
that I don't know mine I don't no I was
a [ __ ] bluffinger I speak for this
broad default
God damn half a celebrity he calls you
Bluff yeah she kicked him out man it was
a kicked me out of the line dude I acted
like I never met him before I turned my
back so fast I took I put my back up on
the conveyor belt I was gone
you had no idea who that broad was none
at all dude so here's the thing you
gotta you can't [ __ ] with pre-check but
you can cut in line when they're calling
classes
yeah oh yeah when you're boarding oh
yeah they go a comfort Plus or you know
priority just go I still haven't found
somebody oh really I saw them bounce
somebody too fake an injury easy yeah
you in a wheelchair will be a fighting
first every time it's cruising through
in a [ __ ] scooter Handler
I did pack his bags
yeah
oh man it's a tough look now the flight
situation is pretty good I I know
Diamond's good I'm closing it on gold
and I might go to La for the weekend
just uh that's dude that's what just to
get the status you start flying places
you don't normally need to fly to yeah I
went to Vermont a few times just just
push it over there you gotta earn the
Miles by the end of the year and if not
you you're starting over again I'll stay
silver yeah yeah [ __ ] that so if you get
close and don't make it you can taste it
ah that's [ __ ] you I mean you stay
you don't start from scratch okay yeah
all right yeah so you've earned silver
for next year I'm trying to go for the
gold right you're trying to be like
Andy's Dad here Olympians go for the
goal so hippie's got an eight leg Delta
parlay going
three layovers on my way to Philly
cricket
here trying to get in Delta one
that's so funny too he goes he didn't
make it in Dallas he killed the whole
thing I missed the [ __ ] Dallas he
missed this connection in Atlanta didn't
make it Stephen A Smith's trashing it
um hippie will not be go I assume you're
a lounge guy go to the Delta Lounge the
first this is my first year of dining
buddy yeah that's another thing the
loungewear the lounge where where it's
nice it's nice The Lax one is nice uh
LaGuardia sucks well here's the one in
LaGuardia is like there's no food
Hospital cafeteria and also now
LaGuardia a queen it's five minutes from
my apartment now and they did the
renovations and all that yeah but it's a
[ __ ] three mile walk to the taxi line
now I know and I'm like what because my
whole thing was now the lounge makes it
easier but I used to love the pre-check
and the boarding early because I go I
get out of bed 40 minutes before my
flight yeah
you know yeah
um this is you know
is pretty elitist but the lounges stink
they suck I would rather just go to a
bar and be able to not like I want to be
like let me get a burger and there's a
few Atlanta's the nice one The Hub yeah
that's that's your JFK's all right LAX
is nice you find a nice Jack Nicholas in
one of those places oh I treat you right
I always look for the celebrity though
oh yeah
necklaces police number one head over to
Rainbow bear head over to Randy
Jackson's and get my head on the street
the Kelly Clarkson Burger let's go
I don't mind it triple bacon
um go now I got nothing okay that's it
folks thanks for tuning in
uh do you know how to tie a tie
absolutely okay what's the suit
situation over at that I got two suits I
just bought a new one because I
officiated my little sister's wedding
nice so I thought that would be a good
occasion to get a new suit very nice
would you guess he's mentioned it's all
right they put they throw together an
ice cream right there yeah uh I got like
a it's like a Ralph Lauren it was
discount it wasn't expensive I'm not an
expensive suit guy okay I'd never wear
them sure but I do like wearing them
yeah I always get and it's a pet pee of
mine but I hate it people go you clean
up nice I go yeah I thank you yeah
that's just telling you you're a Schwab
every other day of the week hey you're
typically a real piece of [ __ ] but today
you look all right look like a normal
member of society see what happens when
you take a shower let's see what happens
if you try a little
clean up nice I get that though
absolutely and as much of a fat piece of
[ __ ] you do have a good
um face and body and an aura for a
sweater too you wear a nice good sweater
yeah I'm a winner you cozy up next to
him at a bar
yeah mohair sweater smell the Old Spice
on him a little bit of yarn
he's telling you about some old Tugboat
or something you know talking about New
Bedford a cinnamon whiskey drink yeah
absolutely yeah I'll tell you about old
Connecticut exactly drinking a
Carmichael scrimshaw
speaking of dream uh when's the last
time you left a debit card at a bar nah
I'm pretty good I'm pretty good God I am
very bad all over town Kippy leaves them
well Patty's is a little different for
us because they don't take the card also
I go to bars where I'm known yeah he
goes to three bars
and do you have a black on a wall
anymore what's your Mr fiori seat no you
know what's gonna happen there's gonna
be one when I die they're gonna put it
yeah that might be that where I've been
to bars like that where they go that's
uh Joe seat yeah and then yeah to the
sign of the cross what are you dying
what do you think parachute
bespoke post is back baby oh yeah that
box of Awesome The Box awesome just in
time for fall you like stabbing Bears uh
get yourself a good buck knife yeah Jack
one up guys the throat maybe or your
neighbor or some nice grilling stuff
some or that some grooming yeah you know
some cocktails travel stuff they got it
all baby or you could strangle a deer
with a hammock whatever you want to do
box awesome is pretty cool it's cool guy
stuff it's a cool guy time of year look
sharp feels sharp do yourself a favor
pick up a boss box of Awesome from our
good friends with bespoke yeah guys it's
easy peasy to get started take the quiz
at box of awesome.com your answers we'll
help you pick them the right box of
awesome for you I did it they keep
sending [ __ ] to my door I am Johnny cool
guy with the name hey what's up with
this I got the [ __ ] drink mix the
torch where you smoke out this
I used to smoke crack too they release
new boxes every month across a ton of
different awesome
crack of awesome each box is valued
around 70 beans but you only pay a half
a fraction of that price plus with each
box of awesome you're supporting small
business 90 of everything that comes in
your box of Awesomeness from a small up
and coming brand it's free to sign up
you skip a month or cancel at any time
it's easy peasy try it out see what you
find get 20 off your first monthly box
when you sign up at box of awesome.com
enter the code garbage at checkout
that's boxingwalson.com code garbage for
20 off your firstbox.com
what's your bar in the story that you go
to uh oh let love in okay yeah all right
and then the Rover
I don't go to the story that much
because I'm always in the city doing
shots so it's always it's patties and so
handlings it's uh Levitt Street Bar 11.
she's got 11th Street bar is that where
your birthday was right that was my
birthday I did the owner is an old buddy
of mine from college he bought it like
three years ago Danny Sweeney great guy
shout out to Danny 11th Street Bar go
there yeah it's nice nice Watering Hole
oh it's a great Irish bar but no I'm
pretty good at like signing you know why
because it's expect for the bar which I
have you know like
I drink a shitload but you I don't ever
want to be the reason you know don't
ever cause noise back in the day exactly
Kippy kind of hit not did it on purpose
but I mean we've all had our moments if
if you got away with leaving the tip for
48 hours that probably helped yeah I
never did it on purpose no uh
uh I would I just did it not too long
ago I do it oh where was I oh this is
wild I was at the stand right and I I
left my credit card there like literally
two years ago or like 18 months ago
never went picked it up got a new one
yeah when
a year and a half later opened up a tab
light started flickering closed down I
was like hey I went up I'm like hey can
I close out
and since I was a comic or whatever like
oh it's you're good but they gave me my
old card back from 18 months and I went
to use it and like everything was I was
getting denied all day I'm like this is
[ __ ] crazy that's so funny I'm like
oh this is from two years ago so I
couldn't go back in and be like hey yeah
I was drunk 18 months ago and left one
here that's the one you gave me you also
still have my real one let's hope no
here's the thing I use my debit card too
often to not have it on me like I would
you know you cannot realize you have it
I needed for the cab ride home you know
I still you know like taking a yellow
taxi I don't like taking the car rides
really you're you're a Yellow Cab man
that's now cheaper it is now cheaper
yeah he's real old school New York I
love it all right
hey Yellow Cab no I I respect like uh
the Integrity of that sentence came out
wrong as soon as I heard it the
Integrity of the bar to to you're an
alcoholic yeah
kid likes to move how red his face is
do you have any uh do you want any two
dollar bills uh I don't but my dad boy
did he have a coin collection real that
I now own really yeah it always buying
infomercial coins at two in the morning
whoa we have them all he didn't set the
sleep timer I guess
oh these old guys are up pissing every
20 minutes you're gonna see a lot of
Infamous they got QVC Sacagawea starts
catching your attention anything worth
anything no they're all [ __ ] my mom
she was like see what she can get for
I'm like this is all sentimental value
yeah that's the only value dude man
that's funny wow okay left money around
the house my mom's moving now she's like
moving to a condo you know she's down
scaling down yeah she goes I found 400
underneath the bathroom sink wow old
school mentality yeah just have cash on
hand in case you need it you got to go
down there and take a lap dude she goes
if I don't get rid of the house and I
die she goes comb this house for cash
because who knows where your father left
money yeah dude totally my uh should be
down there
my uncle did that was redoing the
basement yeah and it was like an old
there was like a you know 100 year old
guy caught an old couple that lived
there their whole lives yeah and he was
redoing the basement found like eight
grand there's nine ten Grand or
something yeah you gotta stow it away
Jesus yeah
that's old school you're peeing in the
shower I assume absolutely brushing your
teeth in there nope I do that over the
sink uh electric toothbrush regular
tooth electric you floss it every day
not at all okay although I'm thinking
about getting a water pick oh I tried it
floss it's very I love it it's the only
thing I do you know Waterpik seems like
it would be reasonable yeah waterpik's a
lot the it's I don't know it's just not
convenient for me didn't seem to do it
what I do recommend it takes up a lot of
counter space in the [ __ ] bathrooms I
don't have yeah yeah I keep it not in I
can't keep it I have like a thing in the
hallway where I keep it but I recommend
uh do you do it out in the hallway no
okay it's also just like
and plug it in
it's no you don't have to plug it in
it's charged oh it is also charge huh
yeah it's like a vape it's pretty good
yeah charging my vape bro no it's like
it's uh it's a weird whatever it's right
next to the door to the bathroom that's
kind of like but no good
your mouth Falls with water like I don't
know I can never get it cooking to the
point where I go Oh I Feel clean
yeah I mean for me it's better than
nothing at my point try the picks like
the the little I'm telling you dude
there's one called Glide that's like I
know glass it's like orgasmic when it
goes in really great yeah yeah all right
it's not like traditional floss you
don't got to get in there in and out
telling you I'll give it a world give it
a shot Andy do you know your mailman
Kinda Yeah we're on we're on a heads up
okay we're not name not first name basis
but when he's around he's a young guy
full uniform full uniform full uniform
the younger crew gets a little lacks a
days ago with him yeah
there's two there's actually two guys
one guy he puts his phone on top of the
mailbag and he just pushes and he
watches his programs okay but then the
other guy is a little more formal he's
the one I know but you know Queens is
it's more residential so everybody does
sure but yeah let's just go hey man how
are you no first name though not bad I
haven't talked about this I got a hot
Dominican chick now God really is hot
young Dominican chick it's crazy oh my
God it's the crazy form she's got the
shorts on she's got a tight t-shirt
she's out smoking Newport 300s dude
these things are huge she's out there
you're sending yourself birthday cards
a lot of junk mail today huh
bet that was pretty hot huh
another letter from the large penis
inside I believe that
it's twice this week
the LPS
sending me my Achievement Award a
Lifetime Achievement Award for huge dong
itis
fantastic
LPS the society
not just the society you open them up in
front how's the [ __ ] [ __ ] inside
you got any fireworks in the house not
in my apartment but you can bet they're
at my mom's house okay really we have a
big uh our whole block Fourth of July
it's Fourth of July so it's like a
neighborhood thing that's awesome when
is she moving out of there it's the end
of this month is she keeping the house
or is she nah sold it ah yeah do you
know the people no damn I know you gotta
get down there dude I'm a little sad I
can imagine next week yeah if I can comb
the walls a little bit I know I know
yeah that's a bummer yeah a little bit
but it's it's not the house we grew up
in but it's right down the street from
the house we grew up but you guys moved
right down the street they moved there's
one in between
one house so this is the third house
I've lived in I I actually never lived
in this house I was already in the city
but my parents when we were like 14 I
was 14 they moved across town and then I
had graduated when my sister graduated
college my English is seven years
younger than me uh they downsized okay
but might they liked that neighborhood
and they were like yeah we just bought
it Indian Head Road there you go how far
tonight
Indian Head Road yeah uh it's nice it's
private it's like
one house in between so they moved
they're very spaced out it's we're
woodsy you know woodsy yeah okay what's
the condo situation your mom's looking
at nice joint yeah three bedroom okay uh
one floor
okay elevator building
that's yeah pretty standard I just like
that security that the [ __ ] ever went
down the toilet I know I got a spot
exactly you know you got us three
bedrooms now you got a spot right
elevator you're talking about a studio
no I know I'm already trying to figure
out which bedroom I can take I think
I'll get your posters up
my got a good frame guy down there
well you put the bunk beds in here
I don't hear any [ __ ] about a sewing
room now how the studs in this new place
can they hold a 30-inch TV
I would stop their metal what are we
talking to you I gotta get my ma on I
gotta get her some TVs hung on the wall
she's still got a cabinet okay and she's
ready to bring it over again we can save
so much space it's this [ __ ] huge
thing and it's a stupid 20 inch you know
like the first flat screen ever sure
because she doesn't care she just got a
smartphone literally she called me today
she goes first phone call
she got an iPhone like six you know and
like she's like you got to teach me how
to do all the tricks and the gadgets
it'll drive me nuts she's okay though
she like once she learns it she'll be
okay but she fought this so long she's
because she was a flip phone up until
yesterday they're shutting off 2G it's
just shutting down wait she's got two
G's she had she's fine she literally
finally up this one's standing Furies
the clam shell and there you go we're
cutting it off you won't be able to use
2G in this country so you gotta go to
Guatemala to use it yeah knights in a
weekend so my little sister took her to
Verizon they got her you know an iPhone
6 and she could yeah she could take
pictures now and like I don't know maybe
we'll get her on the gram there you go
get her on the ground get her on the
ground Graham on the gram hashtag check
right check out the newspaper I need
everybody pushing this guy
get on the gram I need eyeballs get over
there we did it we dropped a promo today
Boogie Nights reference the Boogie
Nights it's a real film Jack oh I saw I
I saw yay I'll put it all up on YouTube
and [ __ ] that's awesome yeah
I like it I like getting fun with the
promos I you know I love doing the movie
references big movie yeah yeah I think
it's just fun maybe we'll recreate a
Seinfeld one there you go yeah that'd be
fun have you ever gone to a midnight
movie and dressed up
no that's a great question but I did I I
have started to see my favorite movies
from when I was a kid in the theater
that I never saw in the theater like I
never saw Jaws in the theater okay I
just went and saw the 50th Anniversary
Godfather okay
what a ride that was in the computer
there's a I would like I would really
like that I talk about it a lot but I
was dating this girl in New York and
they reissued uh they put E.T back out
in theaters yeah and dude our
relationship was on the rocks at the
time I was in a real bad spot mentally
financially and physically and man about
halfway through it I'm balling my
[ __ ] eyes out I cried from the middle
of the movie all the way to the end and
then he gets back on the space
I was crying so hard when we left Athena
that she walked to the other side of the
street and walked down it broke up with
me like the next day
dude it got me so hard E.T H Foley go
home
[Laughter]
the funniest one of the funniest things
I've ever heard in my entire life is Big
Jay oakerson used to describe he goes
one time I saw the worst vagina I ever
saw it looked like when E.T was dying
down with the river
made me [ __ ] cry because we all know
exactly sure
poor little guy
um they left them there all right let's
do a couple from the patreon here again
shout out to it guys when you sign up
for patreon we won't answer your garbage
question on the air we have a little bit
of a backlog but we're working through
it it's just the best way to do we get
submissions people hit us up on
Instagram everywhere guys patreon gets
first crack at it I'm sorry although we
love everybody be a homie not a bozo
um let's see here did your this is from
crawdad man did your parents ever take
you to the horse track no I've never
been to a horse track I've never even
been wow wow it's a good time
we would go as kids a little my step
mom's dad that's a
that's a stretch
um it would take us he was a big uh your
step grandfather Yeah but he called him
by his regular name though yeah yeah
that was Grandpa Jim yeah
it was just hey Jim how you doing Mr Jim
James for the first couple weeks Jimbo I
uh you don't have to be 18 or 21 to go
to the train to gamble no to go okay 18
to gamble that was also the first time
because we were big degenerates that was
the first legal bet I ever placed right
was we went as kids of the to the Philly
racetrack as like a whole family yeah on
the weekends they on I think on sat in
Philly on Saturday and Sunday I think
they run it's a great you're outside
it's fun the kids like the horses the
whole night that's real dirt back
mentality my kind of thing it used to be
BYOB so you roll up with a cooler you
post up put a couple of bucks on the
ponies catching your ziggies outside the
biggest Dirtbag thing is that you had to
say first legal bet sure [ __ ] [ __ ]
hey Spain's been sitting in Ivory liquid
BYOB is uh bowling bbyob they do yeah
that's a tough one right where do they
do that [ __ ] Bryn Mawr Pennsylvania
that's what we did in college we used to
on Friday after three o'clock we'd take
a 30 case we take a rack and split into
like teams of three and you'd [ __ ]
just have to get competitive and you
just pound [ __ ] Natty lights and
that's why you started your weekend dude
I was talking about this with my college
boys the other day the funnest times
we've ever had just a 30 rack and three
on three bowling you compare your scores
kicking things off oh dude that's a fun
time I would do that right now
uh put it on the AmEx yeah anything BYOB
Philly's bit Philly's big on BYOB
restaurants which yeah I love you roll
in
six pack it's like they'll ice
everything down for you I mean taking
beer to a BYOB it's supposed to be a
couple bottles of wine right as a family
I remember being in a couple I think
there's this place from the boot uh in
uh Washington Hill or something over
there
um it was a big deal we went out to
dinner for the first time there my
brother ended a place and we walked we
rolled in there with a cooler a couple
of yinglings if you're gonna do beers
it's got to be bottles you can't be sure
BYOB restaurant North Jersey hot 22s
BYOB strip club so yeah so uh
Pennsylvania yeah
[Laughter]
listen here's the deal I'm really upset
with you guys you've been hiding the
most
I've been drinking with them every
weekend
we'll hang out next time Toby come on
man hey it's all right
you know what it is on a strawberry for
me and my friends
I just did the Seinfeld guy's paw the
other day I came up oh these pretzels
are making me thirsty oh that one shout
out we've done it I've done it if you
did it I've not gotten a chance to do it
I'm looking forward to it it's so fun
they're so funny yes I am no you're not
he asked you two years ago
you gotta do it now I've been jammed up
what do you mean I'm in Jerry
[Laughter]
I would love to fight I would love to go
uh bowling in New York City is a goddamn
atrocity they only have that one in
Brooklyn I know yeah they got the lights
in the backgrounds of [ __ ] it's not a
mom and pop just go away you don't want
that rock and roll [ __ ] 50 bucks to
rent these piece of [ __ ] shoes and it
costs like 80 bucks an hour and yeah I
mean it's a real [ __ ] year there's a
place for my mom called Facenda Whitaker
Facenda Whitaker and somebody got shot
there like a couple months ago it's the
perfect kind of spot little shitty
arcade off to the side yeah you need a
mozzarella sticks or fire yeah we had uh
I'm having my next birthday party there
Brunswick Zone it's a great time
when I was in college you come home for
the summer and on like Tuesday nights
they did dollar bowling and dollar beers
but they had to pay full price for the
shoes which you didn't mind because
you're getting a dollar beers you know
what I mean you beat them up on that end
of it don't worry when we make it up at
shoes guys they're gonna it was like
offer I'm like listen I'm gonna charge a
full pressure shoes just say okay hey
beat him up on a beer beers are a nickel
shoes are eight grand you know there's
one guy in that group that goes I
brought my own man
there's always a kid that tried to bowl
without him man those floors will take
you out I stole a pair in high school
one time we went on a ski trip to
Vermont a high school sponsored ski trip
then I ganked a pair again
like Burlington
oh I love that show to a mixer wearing
those
you can show up to the ballet big velcro
strap over there I just smell like
chemicals uh all right this one's from
Alex and the same thing same vein of uh
uh class strips is it garbage for your
high school to take your class on a
field trip to the local jail
we did that was like scared I was gonna
say Scared Straight No we did just to
like learn when we were learning about
government we went to the courthouse and
then the jail well we couldn't make it
to the jail because something popped off
that day
so they just kids quickly quickly
quickly nobody wear red nobody wear red
that was the day they transferred the
Iceman
I you know what you might have jogged
the memory I think we went to the
courthouse yeah so we were supposed to
do the courthouse and then we were
supposed to do the jail the courthouse
usually has a small jail
that got you know whatever some [ __ ]
popped off that day so we just did the
local one in the courthouse yeah
now [ __ ] that we went to that guy caught
smoking cigs at the Burger King we did
the Hatfield plant Ben Franklin
Institute that field plan yeah that was
it yeah what are you gonna pick up a job
application
these guys stink take the idiots down to
the Hatfield plant ah so this is where
you cut their throats huh all right if
you just go into a rendering plan
what do you do with those horses
Hey You Like Glue don't you kid shut up
you're like doing those arts and crafts
stop crying
[Laughter]
Chuck it in
hurry up you little fat bastard the
vat's cooling off I
thought they make glue out of it the vet
this one that is there's so many Vats
why don't you use a good vat
that's fun times yeah it's good I
thought I had more there
I was waiting for something to be honest
love a fat good fat uh this was from
Oliver my question is a garbage you eat
cereal out of a cup
which I found I remember the I remember
how the day I found out my brother was
like just put it in a cup and let's go
outside and I was like
yeah blew my mind I mean it's not I
don't know if I disagree with it it's
just it's too small a vessel it's true
it's more of a snack one more Golden
Grahams than that what more blew my mind
was when I realized you didn't have to
use a cereal bowl you could use a mixing
bowl now we're talking and also when I
realized upper wear was big for his dad
yeah I think we make the zenience it's
got the red [ __ ] on it
the this bowl of cereal in a tupperware
oh man absolutely close it up Shake It
Up get everything all wet yeah get it
nice yeah and also too the up step from
the teaspoon to the tablespoon was big
for me very big yeah very very big I
remember going over uh I had a sleepover
one time and the kid that we were having
this yeah life added sugar
the first time I ever saw it blew my
mind really we weren't just like my mom
never played that opposite to us sugar
yeah a lot of cereal I went what is that
my mom did I have a special cake because
I was pissed there was no Frosted Flakes
you gotta juice up a life or a Cheerio
yeah a Rice Krispies oh forget it that
that was standard operating procedure at
the house of crazy because my mom
wouldn't get a sugar cereal but she
would get his Cheerios or Rice Krispies
and she would sprinkle it with sugar
yeah straight to the source let's go
living [ __ ] a little blue magic on
there let's do it beating around the
bush no kidding I'm here pure as a bone
stepped on let's go
stepped on I don't want that street [ __ ]
yeah give me the good stuff I don't want
that Kelly's got his fingers in it
do the math myself
um all right let's see this one's from
Sean is it garbage to consider certain
types of jams or spreads as fancy we
thought marmalade was for Rich folk yeah
yeah I thought it was too depends but if
it comes in a nicer jar other than like
Smuckers all fruit might as well have
been eight grand the bottle I don't even
know what that is it's the tall thin
European looking one yeah polander all
fruit if you're calling anything a
spread sure it's not jelly right well
you only got we got grape jelly remember
that commercial we're past the jelly
yeah like I remember that hillbilly it
was uh oh yeah I think it was polander
maybe yeah I do remember somebody will
know somebody exactly yeah
some redneck and there was also he was
like a nice like pasta marmalade and
then be like pass the jelly
there you go damn yeah man what a
[ __ ] snipe that was look at that yeah
we didn't get did you what what did you
what did you get peanut butter jelly
wise was it strawberries [ __ ] smucker
strawberry grape Smuckers grape jelly or
grape Jam
IE jelly here's the thing I not I'm not
too accurate on that because I didn't
love the peanut butter and J I like just
the PB and bread wow I'm a big p man
myself yeah a lot of kids yeah I was
just playing a part I like playing
things plain pizza no peanut butter
really I wanted one thing
yeah if you want to be such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] get this guy out of here
I thought it'd be a strawberry jam kind
of guy I can't I'm sorry I can't help
you uh all right this one's from Foley
lies uh he calls himself a half a gram
homie here you'll know what that means
uh always knowing exactly how much money
you have
trash oh yeah which I guess if you're I
do if it's in a yeah down to the penny
yeah yeah if it's in a world I guess
that's that's another assumption of like
it's countable and you're worried about
it always we clearly know my situations
we know how much money he doesn't have
here's the thing too I think if you grow
up without money you always know how
much money you have yeah and I don't
think that'll ever leave you even if you
make money you still will always have
that in your head I did this to him uh
we we were
we were on tour with Bert we were in
like Las Vegas he has no idea how much
money he has oh no he I think he forgets
yeah no but like we're supposed you know
we have this beautiful thing going on
we're out doing this awesome stuff and
I'm leaning over to Kevin going look at
that right there 38 cents I could have
sworn if something was moved out of my
account he's got his Navy Federal
Banking App out going something's wrong
here and I go I doubt it man they do
they do 5 million transactions a day and
you're an idiot so it's probably I had
him added up numbers I'm like what's 200
my phone out I'm going 200 and first of
all it's like the most elementary math
in the world it's like 200 plus five
plus ten plus a hundred I'm like okay
what do you got what do you got over
there yeah we should have been focused
on this this great thing I want to see
if you got the same number I did yeah
he's like I don't know then he's on then
he's on I I gotta call them okay he's on
speakerphone with navy I'm like flipping
coupons over there or what no that's
just like he has a his hand he suffers
from a bad case of paranoia five dollars
he thinks Navy Federal's stealing money
from him all the time well they got
these fishing scams they they take a
little off at first to see if you notice
and then they hit you with the big one
that ain't gonna work with me it's all
in shorts It's A Bank
I don't know I don't like it it's the
principle The Big Short unfolded yeah
right
yeah
they whack you over that sell sells big
shorts with Fuller wears in the
summertime
[Laughter]
the rip shorts
uh all right let's do this one we got to
get out of here some Alfredo twenty
dollar homie there you go there you go
uh is the garbage have fake fruit as a
centerpiece at the kitchen table 105
dude that's all we had I would argue I
would argue it's still there The Grapes
always look delicious we would chew on
them and they would they would stay
there there's a little hole and they
would stick to your tongue absolutely I
would choke on them sometimes my mom
would yell at me we would juggle the
[ __ ] oranges it was joking Hazard
dude it was oh we love that's all fake
fruit there was a kind not the wax ones
but the rubber ones if you took the
grapes off the vine you could put you
could squeeze it put it in a little
water and do a little get a little
squirt out of it I would take those oh
yeah they would stick
we gotta wrap it up ah what a great time
thank you so much the new special out
right now Andrew fury on YouTube check
right please do yourself a favor YouTube
slash Andrew Fury tell a friend check
right tell a friend check them out of
patties this Friday yeah seriously no uh
and if anybody what does this come out
Thursday uh I'm not sure yet well if
you're in the city Thursday April uh
April October 6 come down we're doing
the thing at spikes on 14th and a 7 P.M
we're having a little release party I
would love to has the ayg army love it
say hi thank you buddy anything else you
want the folks up there to know plug
social media anything uh depending on
Souljers uh in Pottstown or some one of
those wherever soldiers is Saturday
October 8th uh Borgata AC October 14th
the 16th Charlotte Comedy Zone 20
through the 22nd andyfiore.com for uh
all the dates and all the links and yeah
just watch the special I think you guys
will like it tell a friend uh I'm proud
of it so I hope you'll like it you're
one of the funniest buddy and we love
you guys I love you guys so much what do
you got for him guys we're all over the
road check out those uh those tickets we
had to show them Providence had a show
in Boston those are going to sell out so
get those tickets now come see us in Hot
Land it's going to be a good time
Atlanta and Charlotte as well we love
you gang we'll see you next week peace